that would be like Walmart open
operations in North Korea there are
situations where being bad is highly
advantageous when you put forth effort
you get reward you should be constantly
revising your conclusions I think you
have to very consciously differentiate
yourself from where you think your
professional peer group is going he
didn't want to work he had bad habits he
had a bad attitude the systems that
surround doggy healthcare and human
healthcare are profoundly different you
need to practice to have apprenticed for
10,000 hours before you get good if you
are a doctor you have to understand that
you are in the relationship business
we're just going to be doing this for
the entire game and you're going to be
exhausted then he's a Canadian
journalist
best-selling author and speaker he's
been a staff writer for The New Yorker
since 1996 he's written five books all
five of which have been on a New York
Times bestseller list
he's Malcolm Gladwell and here his top
ten rules for success it's not enough to
have a great idea and the focus and the
conscientiousness to see it to fruition
you must have the strength and the
resolve and the courage to pursue that
idea even when the rest of the world
thinks you're insane time and time again
if you look at the stories of
extraordinarily important entrepreneurs
there is almost always a moment when
they are the only ones who believe in
the value of what they're doing you know
I tell in my book the story of my book
David and Goliath the story of ingre our
comrade the guy who founds IKEA and the
crucial moment in the in the story of
IKEA is when he faces a boycott from the
other furniture manufacturers in Sweden
and he's about to go out of business and
in desperation he moves his operations
across the Baltic Sea from Sweden to
Poland and sets up shop in Poland and
that's what IKEA is IKEA is essentially
furniture ship flat made in Poland
that's the original
elevator pitch for IKEA what's
interesting about that is he does it in
1961 at the height of the Cold War at a
time when Eastern
West Communist world and free world are
closer to outright war than at any other
time in history a guy living in the West
Sweden
crosses the pond to Poland the Iron
Curtain and sets up shop you cannot
imagine what a controversial move that
was that's like that would be like
Walmart open operations in North Korea
literally it's on that level of kind of
eyebrow raising you've got to be kidding
me
who is this guy kind of thing but he
does it and he persists and he turns his
back on all those critics why because he
is a deeply disagreeable person didn't
need people to agree with him right and
that's how he's able to build IKEA into
this extraordinary runaway success story
that's very hard to do as human beings
we are hard-wired to want the approval
of our peers there were situations where
being bad is highly advantageous and you
know if you read I don't win to this in
the book but if you've read you know
innovators dilemma
that's what innovators dilemma is all
about right the disruptive outsider is
the one who is incapable of meeting the
marketplace needs as the market is
traditionally defined they can't do it
right so what do they do they they try a
completely new half-assed approach which
in the beginning doesn't work right but
but at very nature of trying something
completely outside the mainstream they
end up appending Lee were they any good
they would never be forced to do that so
it's the same kind of principle when you
put forth effort you get reward when you
throw your heart and mind and soul into
something you get something back now in
my book I call that notion that belief
that effort brings reward meaningful
work and when you look at the lives of
people who are really successful what
you see over and over again is this idea
of meaningful work is embedded in their
consciousness you know I tell the story
of the book of um of the Beatles
everybody knows about the Beatles they
come here in 1964 and the British
Invasion the most interest
thing about the Beatles is what happened
to them before they came to America in
1960 and 1959 when they were just kids
they went they were invited to go to
Hamburg in Germany to be the house band
at a strip club and they went there and
they stayed there for months on end and
seven days a week
they played eight-hour sets
night after night in this strip club
right and over the course of that
extraordinary crucible that experience
of playing they taught themselves how to
be a great band right in fact we know we
think now that by the time the Beatles
came to America they had played together
as a live band 1200 times we could go to
all of the clubs on Friday night in San
Francisco or all the promising young
bands are playing I submit to you would
not find a single band that is played
together 1200 times right just doesn't
happen so what made the Beatles special
what made them special is that they were
willing to play together 1200 times
willing to play eight-hour sets seven
nights a week for months at a stretch
and why were they willing because they
believed in the notion of meaningful
work they had an opportunity to throw
their heart and mind into something and
get something back and that made all the
difference in the world when Dick
Nesbitt he makes a turn in his career as
a psychologist where he goes from
remember he thinks the fundamental
attribution error in the beginning is
fundamental and then he realizes
actually no it's cultural and he does
any puts out it doesn't refute the
fundamental attribution error it deepens
our understanding of it to say oh
actually it has roots in Western culture
but you see a very different and
actually then he writes that book about
east west which is incredibly
fascinating so he gets two great books
out of going back and going over and
correcting his earlier position that to
me is the model for how you ought to
behave in the intellectual world which
is I think should always double back and
say when I want to it this is more
complicated here we can kind of
and contraction is too strong a word
it's but you should you should be
constantly revising your conclusions I
think my strategy has always been you
can't you have to very consciously
differentiate yourself from where you
think your professional peer group is
going so the to the extent that people
are might extend to people migrate to
things that are accessible online I feel
I should all migrate to things that are
inaccessible online so the value or to
extend to people stop reading books and
read I feel like I need to read more
books
so I bench what I've been trying to do
is to kind of it's why I spend a lot of
time in actual physical libraries
reading things in a hardcopy because
there is a kind of serendipity that you
get when you this is not anyway man does
it criticism by the way of search
engines for example which are incredibly
useful but they are but they you know
they also have limitations they reward a
certain kind of serendipity and they
punish another kind of serendipity right
and if you really want to if you're
interested in serendipitous learning as
I am much of what I uncover is uncovered
serendipitously you have to be a student
of all of the different mechanisms of
chance encounters with the unusual and
the insightful and so that means that
not only do I spend a lot of time
screwing around online on databases but
I also very very consciously make sure
that I go to physical libraries and walk
through the stacks and even something as
simple as you're interested in one book
and then you go and you just look at all
of the books that surround it right and
the connections are not always the
connections are there's their
connections between them but it's a
different kind of connection than they
would be connected online it's not a key
word connection right it's a thematic
connection or its set so as always sort
of you have to be a student of these
kinds of of the the different ways in
which ideas cluster
and so that and I've been I thought a
lot about that in recent years as a way
of distinguishing myself from other
journalists I remain I'm uninterested in
that topic Tom which one whether the
relationship between gift and practice
now I want to trust it in natural gifts
yeah I know they exist and I know
there's such a thing as talent but it's
not about that but I just feel like so
and so what right because there are
people and I always think of your
basketball fan
Iowa's like of Derrick Coleman yes I
remember chatting with a guy who worked
for the Sixers and he said you have to
understand the Derrick Coleman was the
most gifted man ever to set foot on a
basketball court he said I you I could
you know you've heard a million other
names
nobody was as good as Derrick and like
who has heard today who thinks who puts
Derrick Coleman up there in the pantheon
no one he didn't want to work he had bad
habits he had a bad attitude I mean so
what give me somebody who wants to go to
practice in the morning and it wants to
try in games and I want to celebrate him
if someone were to follow you from the
inception to you know sort of picking a
story or identifying a study to the full
book what happens along the way well we
know I mean sometimes I start uh you
know there are about five or six times a
year I go to them
NYU library and I spend a couple days
just browsing is too mild a term but
wandering around going through millions
of journals in the most sort of
serendipitous way I can just to kind of
see what's out there and see if I can
stumble on something so without a clear
goal or Direction notice or no go ever
so there's that I do as a regular basis
and then I I do a fair amount of
speaking I always try and have
conversations with people well outside
my world so today I gave a talk this
morning and in Philadelphia and I was
talking to a guy one of the guys there
was runs a medical devices company very
small one and so I started talking to
him about because I've always had this
idea in my head that it'd be really
really fun to write to compare the
dogs are treated with the way humans are
treated in it because they're not that
dissimilar as problems for medical
science but if the yet but the the the
systems that surround doggy healthcare
and human health care are profoundly
different right so you know I the same
devices are used in various you know hip
implants or not the same but analogous
devices only you do a complex knee
surgery on your dog at 7,000 dollars and
you do it on a human being it's 100 now
is human really 15 times more complex
than a dog when it comes to know so
there's something but anyway this I had
this vague thought and I met this guy as
I started asking about this and he
should have started riffing on it gave
me his card now that's sort of how it
works you mean like you take advantage
of a little thought you had in your head
and when you meet someone by accident
who happens to have specialized
knowledge you make sure you get his card
so a bunch of group of really brilliant
psychologists in the field of expertise
research have sat down and tried to
figure out how long do you have to work
at something before you become really
good right and the answer seems to be
it's an extraordinary consistent answer
in an incredible number of fields and
that is you need to have practice to
have apprenticed for 10,000 hours before
you get good so every great classical
composer without exception composes for
at least ten years before they write
their master work
Mozart 1030 is composing at 11:00 but
he's composing garbage at 11:00 I mean
he doesn't produce something great until
he's 22 or 23 concerto number nine I
think 271 if I asked you how long did it
take you when you were doing this job
before you felt comfortable and good at
what you were doing 10 years old yeah I
was same with me when I didn't got to be
consistent finding in it it's really
important because it says that we are
far too impatient with people when we
when we assess whether someone has got
what it takes to do a certain job we
always want to make that assessment
after six months or a year or and that's
ridiculous you know the kinds of jobs we
have people do today are sufficiently
complex
they require a long time to reach
mastery and what we should be doing is
setting up institutions and structures
that allow people to spend the time and
effort to reach mastery not judging them
prematurely if you are a doctor you have
to understand that you are in the
relationship business if you are in a
ship where you have to understand that
what you are interested in is the supply
chain from A to B not in managing some
transaction along the way if you're in
the radio business you have to
understand that you are not selling our
box you are selling an experience right
those are the rules of the modern
economy and those who grasp those rules
are the ones who thrive and succeed and
are capable of transforming the
industries that they're a part the
choice you have as an underdog is if
you're going to choose to fight and
choose to fight to win there are a
series of strategies available to you
but they are all more costly than the
strategies available to the favorite so
I give the example of a chapter about a
and a software mogul in Silicon Valley
an Indian guy who coaches his daughters
twelve-year-old daughters basketball
team and they are without talent they
are by his own by his own admission this
was like they didn't know how to barely
know how to play the game it takes them
all the way to the national
championships he does it by he instructs
them they're going to play the
full-court press every minute of every
game and defend every inch of the court
right now that's actually a very
effective strategy particularly in age
class basketball if you're the underdog
it's your only chance of winning is to
play a really aggressive defense it
requires however that everyone in your
team expend maximum effort every minute
of the game you cannot loaf for an
instant you have to be in really good
shape and you have to run yourself
ragged and you cannot let up most people
will not play that way because it's too
difficult if I said to you we're not
going to be doing does this
elegantly designed plays and shooting
gorgeous baskets and passing the ball
we're just going to be doing this for
the entire game and you're going to be
exhausted at the end most kids would say
and that's not why I signed up so it's
like that's a kind of classic
illustration of that effort effort is
the route one of the routes available to
the underdog
I can outwork you even if I may not be
able to outspend you but I can outwork
you well how working is a tall order is
not easy to do you know that's as anyone
who has worked in a start-up knows
that's this one of the stressful parts
of it but successful startups I am I've
never seen any actual data on this but
do we think the people working for
successful startups work longer hours
than people who work for fortune 500
companies my guess is yes thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Jim Jiang asked me to so there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Malcolm
Gladwell's top 10 rules meant the most
to you at the biggest impact leave it in
the comments and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon